the early morning train from la viv is
slow but it's made it
the carriages are full of passengers
young and old weary but relieved
for now poland is their new home
but this place is full of surprises
because the train back into ukraine is
full of fighting spirit
[Applause]
janina is a teacher and a painter
heading home to odessa which she knows
is in putin's sight now
i really need to be strong
and being strong means
going home even though it might be very
dangerous
yes of course and
we have a good army and i believe that
our people ukrainians
men will
will win
in the middle carriage there's a game of
cards underway
one man's trying to cheat
and for a brief moment thoughts of war
fade
a few seats down we meet marsha her
husband and six-year-old son are 800
miles to the east she can't get to them
so she's going to volunteer to help the
war effort instead
i don't want to see it in egypt or in
portia
when my family sit here
i hope
for this and
maybe
my husband to my family
can
you see me or i can read you one
nearly five hours later we reached
levith and western ukraine
a lot of people i've spoken to here say
they just don't have any choice but to
come back into ukraine their families
are here they need to be here
whether they choose to leave or stay
ukrainians are under enormous pressure
as the weight of war bears down on them
nick martin sky news la viv in ukraine